eggless ahmo's gang is not doing very
well as they come across a bunch of
people whose are early screenings of the
movie I'm gonna give you a math way to
okay
you gonna tell me the answer it's quirky
and weird which to some writers equals
brilliant and mind-blowing how much what
you have if I said I would pay your
penny on the first day and then two
pennies on the second and then four
pennies on the third day and I just kept
doubling and I did this for a month oh I
know this one it's true you everybody
hates math we're all gonna die
buddy notices a hole which he could
easily plug up but doesn't as it causes
them all to naturally go insane my
name's Luigi Mario I'm a Bordeaux we can
Italian raised by a British Italian
who's both my father and my brother I'm
fighting a germophobe dinosaurs turn
Lance Henriksen into a mushroom and
things ordering a pizza is funny
Wahlberg's gang runs across a guy from
the military who also isn't sure what
direction to go cuz 10 about eight miles
behind us
they were bodies on the road into town
she's and crackers we're just hungry
when you wrote this cheese and crackers
hot dogs honeybees was a sponsored by
the Food Network but our weird Shamel on
one shot reveals that other people are
confused where to go as well so they
travel in one large group but one woman
gets a call from her daughter in
Princeton Stella told not to go near the
window at the tree just tell her baby
don't go near the window with the tree
ask her if Princeton's been affected
well I asked her if she liked hot dogs
honey son you talking funny what's wrong
with you how can you tell nobody's acted
normal in this movie since it was green
wet so everybody tries to figure out
where to go next if we go west we'll hit
a County called arendelle dirt roads
hardly anybody lives out there he'll
sing a song so much a oneness day of
your ears out with an ice pick but aside
from that they're cool but something
else in this movie is starting to blow
what firearm is my right right an
austere toaster strudel and syrup my
firearm is my friend Oh
ketchup and hashbrowns grab feces and
Denny's toxin why do you say things like
you're on a kid show where the kids are
supposed to answer back look I don't
know if you guys have heard about this
article in The New York Times about
honeybees vanishing sensor filbert does
anybody know where that is
that's right
Thaksin what no we need to do something
just let me think there's the right I
need a second but we can't just stand on
it both observers don't talk like that
this isn't how we act this is home
computer things we act we're uninvolved
observers probability is very low how
should we react to dead people but math
problem this was a joint writing team
between Hal 9000 and GLaDOS knows what
to do we need a second okay why should
anybody give me a goddamn second I'd be
scientific - Becky back away from the
camera guy you're gonna blow snot on the
lens what if it is the plant oh you mean
that thing we already said it was duh
and TM what the twister what a twister
they find their way into a model house
where everything seems to be fake so
naturally considering their acting they
mistake props for human beings my name
is Elliott Moore just going to talk in a
very positive manner yeah this is
happening people just here to use the
bathroom and which is gonna leave that's
okay until then I hope you don't mind if
we put these folks on our most wanted
list nothing against your kind but
there's anything we Americans like it's
racial profiling but another group of
people are coming so they run past this
obvious metaphor feeling that the group
will become too big and they'll get
infected
Oh again the way they're talking how can
you tell they're not affected decades No
how come you got a problem she went away
you need to take personal responsibility
for yourself in the relationship
hey that's not a toy it's got meaning to
me so the kids are talking about a
meaningful relationship while the adult
is why need to be given his toy ring
back Shyamalan dyslexic with age numbers
does he constantly get him backwards so
after Zoey admits she had tara misu with
a guy late one night and of course she
mentions it was Tara masu because I just
assumed this was all written at a buffet
somewhere Wahlberg decides he wants to
confess something too
just needs a 10-minute residence of food
we should keep going if we're gonna die
I want you to know something I was in
the pharmacy awhile ago it was a really
good looking pharmacist behind the
counter uh didn't you just say you
should keep going this doesn't seem like
the time for pharmacy store confessions
I went up and I asked where the cough
syrup was I didn't even have a call and
I almost bought it Oh No so they decide
to drop by a house is there any way we
can get some food we have a little girl
we just want to get her some food let's
leave now come on we're talking hot dogs
tara misu and cough syrup we need some
real conversations out here ain't gonna
bring that poison gas in here with it
sir it's not poison gas
even if there was all your windows are
open done we're perfectly normal
one black water keep all rollin
Mississippi know what you keep on
shining on me see we're normal you're
the laundry list of not normal
everything you're doing is being written
down in a book called how not to be
normal there is literally a chapter
called seriously I can't make this shit
up so to stop the evil crazy gas from
getting in they do the same thing of
shooting two little boys off their porch
this was brought to you by in the grand
scheme of things really no reason
whatsoever but Lula's awkward dialogue
to listen to it but don't worry that
void is filled by this crazy Broad who
lives in the next house they come across
I suppose the kind thing for me to do is
to offer you supper oh yeah that's what
I do have a random stranger drop by my
place why I my lemon drink I ain't gonna
ask you again
well this place obviously seems safe as
they spend the night but slowly realized
she may not be all there herself
I hear you whispering planning on
stealing something
no ma'am we're not plan on murdering me
in my sleep what no I'm not even gonna
critique this scene it's brought so much
joy and laughter from how famous it is
that it be is sin to critique this scene
but I'm gonna do this for shits and
giggles what
it needed to be done well no it did but
that's what makes it even better
so the lady seems to be acting nuttier
and nuttier as well even the nutty
acting seems a little bit off there's
something happening in a few states in
this region it's not safe now this isn't
a crazy gesture this is a Barbara
Streisand
singing performance it makes a bigger
connection I thought but the tree mojo
seems to affect her too and for an old
lady her heads really got some weight to
it ma'am you can smash a melon with that
melon will bergen Deschanel stay in
separate buildings but are able to
communicate via a very convenient pipe
that allows them to hear each other it's
too dangerous to go outside is it yes
this is the end isn't it man you're fast
to give up it hasn't even been two
minutes yet and already you're like this
is the end this is the end you know
movies can go past an hour and a half
don't begging you not to you remember
our first date you bought me the mood
ring turned purple when you wore it then
we check the little paper chart and it
turned out that purple meant I was horny
always good to teach the kid new
vocabulary words next talk about how
your point together your bondage swing
and I swear I'm not kidding I actually
timed this they wait literally just
three minutes before they decide they
can't take it anymore and they go
outside to die yeah three minutes they
drag the kid out there too man Leguizamo
should have been more specific with that
demand it should have been take my
daughter's hand unless you mean it
what it should have been was don't wait
the length of microwaving a burrito to
sacrifice my daughter to tree demons you
think that go without saying should in
the length of microwaving a hot pocket
but get this it stops just at the point
when they walk outside I think the
actual surprise of this ending is kind
of hard to follow the name of the
location pops up when it shows there
okay
well does that mean they were in a safe
place the whole time if so why did that
woman kill herself
I mean sure she was crazy but what are
the chances she'd had the exact same
craziness that makes you walk backwards
and off yourself after doing so kind of
a long shot but then just to make things
more confusing they say this if it must
have ended before without well wait why
show us the location at that exact time
that what did it matter what was the
real answer of what happened here is
this like clue where we're supposed to
guess our twist ending and yes by the
way that is the ending because two three
months later nobody has any idea how or
why this all happened but Deschanel is
pregnant because that's what this was
all about how does that make any sense
how does any of this make any sense for
trying to figure out how Shambhala keeps
coming back in my reviews even though he
keeps dying right right right yeah your
Shyamalan in a moment I want to see how
my tropes are coming any new
developments yes as you know Jim and I
have solved our problems using symbolism
and my strange quirk is saving the day
and we get it all in one shot
well then it's time to review my big
twist yeah y'all reset its walls no it's
actually something completely different
all right what is it then it's
the walls that's what you just said it
wasn't yeah it's a triple twist
you see I said it was then I said it
wasn't only to reveal it was again
that's why I'm the king of twists I've
been to Zumba classes with better twists
than that women
you guys are Chama waste any more no as
you know that twist was so lame that it
snapped us out of it come on let's go
guys just when I was speaking out of
whip tight oranges - fine go ahead and
tell them not to see my movie then
actually I wasn't going to really you
think it's a cinematic masterpiece no
it's the dumbest thing I've seen in
years that's very entertaining from the
acting to the writing to the directing
everything is completely wrong in this
movie but it's so creatively wrong it's
impossible not to get a laugh out of it
the choices made are so strange and so
unnatural that it's one of the funniest
unintentional comedies you could watch
so yes I highly recommend it not as an
awful drama but as a hilarious comedy
it's guaranteed to get several laughs
out of you well I guess I don't need to
shamah lies anybody then wait I thought
you said the Walsh analyzed everybody no
that was a quadruple twist I said it was
then said it wasn't then said it was now
I'm saying it wasn't again but wait if
you didn't control everyone who did
you
Margie cuz the happening but Ted
Flanders got run over by his lawnmower
Oh
cheese and crackers
hey Doug Walker here once again doing
the charity shout out and this week we
are doing the Junior Diabetes Research
Foundation this is obviously a
foundation that focuses on diabetes
particularly in children mostly dealing
with type 1 diabetes trying to show
children how they can live with it
better finding ways to help people get
through it and on top of that they of
course are looking for a cure this is a
foundation that spends hours and hours
trying to put the latest technology the
latest research the latest information
into finding a cure for type 1 diabetes
I've heard so many people say so many
good things about this organization and
if you look at the videos on their
YouTube channel you can definitely see
not just adults but children as well
really stand by this any time you give
any donation or show any support you are
helping these people find a cure for
this disease you can visit their website
or their YouTube site to see all the
interesting things that they do all the
information they have on it testimonials
insights the whole thing do definitely
check out one of them if not both of
them and see how you can make a big
difference
The Cure is definitely possible with
your help